Welcome to our deep dive into the Master and the Disciple by Jafar Ibn Mansour.
We are unpacking a profound narrating ade.
A son sent home with a six-line operating manual who meets his father's two-horn charge with a 40-year syllogism that closes every door.
What has been received must be transmitted.
This is really an exploration for you, the listener, about the ultimate framework for navigating deep, painful familial disagreements.
Exactly.
Without breaking those underlying bonds of love, because, well, that is incredibly hard to do in practice.
It really is.
So let us establish the starting point.
The young disciple has studied rigorously with the Sheikh and the scholar.
You can think of it like this.
The young disciple's roots have been well watered and his branches have grown tall.
Yeah, he is completely prepared internally.
Yes, it's time to be sent into the world.
And the Sheik has three very specific reasons for releasing the young disciple.
First, the Sheik is about to travel.
Okay, so the daily routine of studying is physically ending.
Precisely.
But the second reason is much heavier.
Back home, the father's sorrow is growing.
And the Sheik recognizes
that finding a profound doctrine does not erase a son's duty to be present for his living father.
That is such a vital check on spiritual arrogance.
Yeah.
You can't just abandon the people who raised you just because you found some elevated path.
Exactly.
You still owe them your presence.
And that leads directly to the third reason, which is really the load-bearing reason of this whole situation.
the obligation of the Quranic covenant.
Okay.
What does that bind him to?
Well, in the chapter on the family of Imran, verse 187, there's an absolute obligation to not conceal scripture from the people.
The education was never meant for his own private consumption.
So he has to go back.
But he doesn't just walk out the door empty-handed, does he?
No.
The Sheikh binds him with four strict counsels before he leaves.
The first rule is the Keystone rule.
Be mindful of Allah.
Which, I mean, sounds standard, but it anchors everything else.
It does.
It is backed by the chapter on the family of Imran, verse 102, and reinforced heavily by the book of eloquence by the father of imams.
If you lack that internal compass, the rest falls apart.
Makes sense?
The second counsel is to uphold the oath.
The 3rd is to safeguard the scholar who acts as the trust bearer on his journey.
And the 4th counsel is to conceal his identity.
Wait, let me jump in here.
Why conceal his identity?
Isn't concealing your identity when calling others to the truth just a form of deception?
I see why you would think that.
But it is not about shame or deception.
Think about what the young disciple is carrying.
It is a vital protection of a delicate thing from the careless hands of a world that does not yet have the eyes to see what the young disciple has become.
Oh, I see.
So it's essentially load management for the listener.
Precisely.
You don't hand a fragile glass sculpture to someone who doesn't know how to hold it.
So following these rules, they travel to the outskirts of the city.
Just the young disciple and the scholar.
Yes.
The scholar names his own residence so the young disciple can find him later.
And then he delivers his parting advice.
And you can view this advice as an operating manual.
Each line is a working rule for a moment, where temper or vanity could break the call.
An operating manual for surviving a family argument.
I love that.
What are the lines?
Line 1, entrust resolution to a law.
Meaning,
you have to free yourself from carrying the outcome before you even walk in the door.
Exactly, because if you need to win, you will fail.
Line 2, speak with words of wisdom, which is only possible if you followed line one.
Yeah, true.
Then we hit the ego defenses.
Line 3, refuse anger when wronged.
Line 4, refuse upset when called a liar.
My.
When your own family diminishes you, the biological instinct is to snap back.
But doing so breaks the call.
Line 5.
Be patient with responders.
Give them time to process.
And finally, line 6, be the best example of what you call others to be.
This entire manual is supported structurally by the chapter on the bee, verse 125, the chapter on science distinguished, verse 33, and the book of eloquence.
I mean, this sounds beautiful in a vacuum.
But isn't this an impossible standard to hold when walking back into an annoyed, deeply emotional family home?
Human beings aren't robots.
It is an incredibly high standard, but the teacher of others needs teaching the most.
He cannot offer medicine if he is coughing from the sickness of ego.
And the young disciple actually demonstrates his profound grounding before he even leaves the scholar.
How so?
He thanks the scholar for three specific things in a very precise architectural order.
First, he gives thanks for the imam whose argument was upheld.
Second, he gives thanks for the trust bearer whose pact was fulfilled.
And third, he thanks him for the corpse given life.
Corpse, meaning himself.
Yes, quoting the chapter on cattle, verse 122.
He realizes he was spiritually dead before this.
He kisses the scholar's feet, turns around, and finally heads home to face the fire.
Walking straight into the tension.
And it is tense.
The father's grief over his son's absence has been so loud it actually annoyed the neighbors.
So the moment he walks in there is no warm reunion.
The father confronts him immediately with the most painful charge possible.
What does he say?
The father says, if you chose a stranger over me and found truth, you concealed it and betrayed me.
But if you were deceived by this stranger, you destroyed yourself and threw away 40 years of my investment in you.
That is a devastating trap.
I mean, either you're a traitor to your blood or a complete fool.
Yes.
It leaves no casual way out.
But the young disciple connects instantly to the prophetic model.
We look at Abraham at first mention.
How does he react?
Like the prophet who confronted his father regarding the worship of unseeing objects.
Found in the chapter on Mary, verses 41 through 50, he presses with deep respect.
He honors the bond.
He offers guidance rather than a harsh verdict.
So he absorbs the blow without attacking back.
He offers two paths to his father.
Silence, meaning outward obedience but hidden disagreement, or open debate without anger.
Giving the father the choice.
Yes, and the father refuses the hypocrisy of silence.
He chooses debate, which hands the young disciple the exact opening he was waiting for.
The trap is set.
And here is the pivot.
The young disciple presses a single argument based entirely on the father's 40 years of life.
He says, Over these 40 years, either you were a scholar of truth who withheld it from your son, and therefore you have no standing to criticize me, or you were ignorant of the truth.
and therefore you need the stranger even more than I do, and you should have preceded me out the door.
Oh, wow.
I mean, that is airtight.
Think of it as two horns of a charge met by two horns of a reply.
Every door the charge leaves open, the reply absolutely closes.
It's A constructive dilemma, completely mapping to Aristotle's prior analytics.
What has been received must be transmitted.
Wait, I don't buy that yet.
Doesn't the syllogism just bully a grieving father?
That sounds like wordplay.
How is constructive dilemma different from rhetorical trapping?
Isn't this just replacing one maternal authority with another by intellectually outmaneuvering an old man?
On paper, yes, that is the exact friction.
If you just drop a logic puzzle on a grieving father, it causes resentment, not conversion.
But here is the invisible move.
The argument did not work merely because it was a perfect logical trap.
It worked because the ground was prepared by the son's gentleness, the father's honesty, and the years of love between them.
The bond inside which the pressing landed was what allowed the old man to finally admit what he had been missing.
Oh, okay.
I actually see it now.
So the logic is merely the container for the love and truth the father was secretly waiting for.
It wasn't a weapon at all.
Precisely.
And because of that, the old man's heart is touched.
His eyes overflow with tears and he enters the path immediately.
no long doctrinal apprenticeship, no waiting.
The young disciple successfully utilized the first four lines of his operating manual in a single conversation.
That is remarkable discipline.
And the stakes are fully realized.
Because the seed was right.
Through father and son, Allah gave life to a great number of people in that country, reflecting the chapter on the table, verse 32.
The awakening just cascaded outward.
What has been received must be transmitted, which leaves us with this question.
Which piece of what we have received are we still holding back from the parent, friend, or colleague who's been waiting for the argument that finally lets them admit they were waiting?